und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend es passiert ja leider nicht oft
dass eine nachrichtensendung mit einem
stück hoffnung beginnen kann
nutzen wir also die gelegenheit im
festgefahrenen aber brodelnden konflikt
zwischen der ukraine und von russland
unterstützten separatisten im osten des
landes gab es heute positive bewegung
gefangenen wurden ausgetauscht ganz im
sinn der vereinbarung von minsk vor fast
fünf jahren zwischen wladimir putin
petro poroschenko francois hollande und
angela merkel die frage ist und bleibt
ob dieser kleine schritt heute der
anfang von fortschritt wird christian
senn berichtet fünf jahre war ich in
einem keller 5 quadratmeter könnt ihr
euch vorstellen was das bedeutet was sie
lisa wien schreit seinen frust raus er
ist jetzt ein freier mann
einer von 200 menschen für die heute die
gefangenschaft endet streng bewacht
beginnt am vormittag der austausch
zwischen der ukraine und den
pro-russischen kämpfern in der nähe der
frontlinie die freigelassenen erzählen
wie schlecht sie jeweils in der
gefangenschaft behandelt wurden
überprüfen lassen sich diese aussagen
nicht die meisten sind glücklich aber
manche auch unversöhnlich
glücklich dass wir jetzt frei sind nach
vier jahren für einige und fünf jahren
für andere befreit von den fesseln des
ukrainischen nazismus wir sind
inspiriert und bereit zu kämpfen
ich wurde zu zwölf jahren haft
verurteilt wegen landesverrats in der
sogenannten lohans gar volksrepublik ich
hatte meine eltern besucht und konnte
die stadt leider nicht mehr verlassen
der gefangenenaustausch war beim ukraine
gipfel anfang dezember in paris
vereinbart worden
es war das erste mal dass sich der
ukrainische präsident sei lenski und
russlands präsident putin persönlich
trafen deutschland und frankreich
vermittelte nun also der versprochene
austausch 76 gefangene wurden den
ukrainischen behörden übergeben unter
ihnen soldaten und mehrere zivilisten
124 gefangenen durften zurück in die
separatisten gebiete mit dabei waren
auch ehemalige mitglieder der inzwischen
aufgelösten polizeispezialeinheit gut
sie werden beschuldigt bei den
massenprotesten 2014 auf dem majdan in
kiew demonstranten getötet zu haben
kritik heute aus kiel diese bergleute
hätten nicht teil dieses austauschs sein
dürfen
die 100 leute die auf dem majdan
gestorben sind dürfen nicht vergessen
werden schmerzhafte kompromisse oder zu
viele zugeständnisse
die ukraine ist gespalten darüber
welchen preis man bereit ist zu zahlen
für einen möglichen frieden wenn die
regierung den konflikt im don was
wirklich beenden will muss sie sich
selbst und unseren bürgern sagen dass
der konflikt noch sehr lange dauern wird
und dass es für diesen keine einfachen
lösungen gibt
vor zwei stunden landeten die ehemaligen
gefangenen in der hauptstadt kiew
empfang von ihren angehörigen und ihrem
präsidenten
das beste ist dass die leute wieder zu
hause sind und wie wir versprochen haben
werden sie das neue jahr im kreise ihrer
familien feiern können für die menschen
hier nimmt das jahr in der ukraine ein
glückliches ende
doch der weg zum frieden ist noch sehr
weit
tja und dann ist ja keineswegs sicher
dass alle seiten diesen weg zum frieden
suchen und dann bereit sind in zu gehen
apropos fortschritte manchmal passieren
sie und wir übersehen dass das
ablaufende jahr 2009 10 war im großen
rahmen gesehen
das wohl beste jahr in der geschichte
der menschheit
jawohl gemessen an der gesamtheit leben
so wenige menschen in extremer armut wie
nie zuvor
weniger als zehn prozent 1980 waren das
noch über 40 prozent
noch nie sind wieder vorläufig und an
der gesamtheit gemessen so wenige kinder
früh gestorben
noch nie konnten so viele menschen lesen
und schreiben furchtbare krankheiten
sind auf der ganzen erde auf dem rückzug
das alles war und trotzdem bleibt auf
unserer insel des wohlstands unwohlsein
mit konflikten und trends die ebenfalls
ganz real sind und unser bewusstsein
bestimmen beobachtungen von christian
kirsch mehr denn je
man spürt es zerren fliehkräfte an
unserer staatlichen gemeinschaft da
gehen die jungen voller zorn auf die
straße ihre wut richtet sich gegen das
phlegma der alten die so der vorwurf den
klimawandel praktisch tatenlos hinnehmen
von kaum tragbaren rentenlasten ganz zu
schweigen und die alten sichern
privilegien und pensionen auf eine
innere deutsche einheit wartet das land
noch immer man erklärt sich im osten oft
zum bürger zweiter klasse der bürger
west weiß oft mehr über die provence als
über sachsen die menschen in den immer
teureren städten verstehen kaum das
leben der anderen auf dem land wo es
platz gibt aber kaum internet dort im
netz redet man immer schneller
übereinander selten miteinander fordert
toleranz doch die verlangt man meist nur
dem anderen ab man verharrt verhärtet in
seiner ecke alles vertreten von
rechthaberei bis hin zum hass
deutschland driftet auseinander arm und
reich stadt und land alt und jung ost
und west wie finden wir wieder
zueinander
ja wie das ist eine gute frage wem
stellt man die am trennungs punkt von
zwei jahrzehnten jemanden aus politik
industrie forschung kultur
wir haben lange überlegt und dann damit
karama nie eine sms geschickt ein
reporter und schriftsteller der sich die
stiefel dreckig macht menschen anspricht
dort vor alarmierende nachrichten
herkommen entlang den gräben heißt sein
grossartiger reisebericht von köln über
berlin durch mittelosteuropa bis in den
iran woher er stammt er wuchs auf im
siegerland studierte in köln kairo und
bonn lebt geerdet im eigelstein viertel
von köln hinter dem bahnhof und will da
nicht weg
gleichzeitig ist der einer den der
bundestag zu einer rede über die
deutsche verfassung einlädt und einer
der den friedenspreis des deutschen
buchhandels bekommt als treffpunkt hat
navi kamali den platz vor dem kölner
hauptbahnhof vorgeschlagen wo silvester
2015 im schatten des doms aggression
entstand musste das so passieren woran
liegt das
also ich glaube das erste was man
feststellen kann das hilft auch um das
zu verstehen ist das passiert nicht nur
in deutschland
das passiert weltweit in verschiedener
form sie sehen das können dass er noch
niedriger beobachten sie kommt es in
indien beobachten nahen osten
diese konflikte in verschiedener form
aber eigentlich ist da ist der kern
komplett immer der gleiche findet
überall statt das heißt das nimmt ein
bisschen das besondere an der deutschen
situation dass wir denken das sei hier
so besonderes was hier stattfindet aber
eigentlich macht die sache natürlich
auch schlimmer macht sich schlimmer aber
sie macht sie vor allem auch ein
bisschen weniger speziell und ich glaube
der blick nach außen hilft um das
eigenes verstehen wir können glaube ich
über ich beobachte dass überall wo die
globalisierung an
sowohl die lebensverhältnisse gleicher
werden wo menschen lebensentwürfe
alltagserfahrungen wie man lebt über
einkaufen was man was man gerne hat im
leben wie die kinder groß werden sollen
das gleicht sich ja überall in den
mittelschichten weltweit an
und das heißt es führt aber
paradoxerweise nicht so dass die
menschen kost politischer werden sondern
im gegenteil dass die sehnsucht noch
etwas eigenes zu haben also etwas etwas
was einen unterscheidet von anderen eher
größer gehen aber überall dort wo das
leben sich rasant verändert oder wo
mittelschichten abzu abzurücken
also wo ist wo sie angst haben dass sie
ihren wohlstand nicht halten können dort
besinnt man sich auf das abzeichen
hauseigene ist halt manchmal die
religion manchmal die nation manchmal
die kultur aber sie sehen das etwas was
eine vom anderen unterscheidet
gleichzeitig fühlen sich menschen die
die alles weiter haben wollen wie bisher
gegen das fremde zu viel wird fühlen
sich von den eliten in der politik in
den medien irgendwie missachtet und
gering geschätzt
ist da nicht sogar was dran wenn man
sich umschaut in den städten da hat sich
ja wahnsinnig viel verändert deutschland
also in deutschland zu bleiben da ist in
einer generation gab sozusagen eine
geradezu demografische wirklichen
demografischen besucher mittlerweile ein
drittel der deutschen oder der hier
lebenden haben eltern die nicht aus
deutschland kommen also das ist in einer
generation passiert das würde in jedem
land der welt würde dass das ängste
hervorrufen und diese diese einwanderung
wurden überhaupt nicht begleitet
politisch das war ja doch unter helmut
kohl galt deutschland als
einwanderungsland und ich glaube dass
das man durch begreifen muss ist dass
vielfalt und auch einwanderung konflikte
erzeugt das geht gar nicht klar es gibt
keinen kein beispiel wurst glatt geht
aber sie ist bietet sich auch viele
chancen also dort wo länder bemühen wo
wirtschaften löwen kulturen aufblühen
also diese goldenen zeiten der deutschen
kultur das war die zeit wo deutschland
einflüssen aufgenommen hat von außen
das heißt man hat oft gar nicht oder die
menschen die das kritisch sehen haben
nicht das gefühl dass jetzt ein goldenes
zeitalter ausspricht die haben das
gefühl es wird bedrohlicher es wird
dunkler es wird fremder ich bin hier
nicht mehr zu hause
die frage ist doch wie geht man damit um
wie wird der streit ausgetragen und da
finde ich das ist in deutschland noch
verhältnismäßig im vergleich zu anderen
ländern auch in europa und zu malen der
welt schauen sie auf nahen osten hin
noch verhältnismäßig friedlich zugeht
schauen sie auf frankreich mit den
gewaltigen sozialen leben in dem bon
dieu
da hat es ja deutschland bis jetzt noch
einigermaßen noch noch noch geschafft
das heißt wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
konflikte normal sind und dass es darum
geht wie sie zu lösen sind also sieht
ist das auch streit normales das streite
zugehört sondern demokratie dass man um
lösung bringt und nicht jeder schon die
lösung parat hat und da ist natürlich in
deutschland über viele jahre gab es
keine öffentliche diskussion über die
themen und dass sich diese diskussion
gibt das ist da auch vielleicht mal
harte thesen gibt dass es dann auch das
ist das ist dann auch mal sagen auch
rhetorisch knallt ist finde ich erstmal
nicht so schlimm hauptsache es bleibt
friedlich
hauptsache ist wiederholen sich so dinge
wie hier in köln in der silvesternacht
nicht gleichzeitig beobachtet man das
überall auf der welt menschen ihre
zuflucht suchen bei starken figuren bei
autoritären führer von trump über
erdogan bist du takte und ball szenario
ist das ein trend der gefährlich werden
kann für die ganze demokratie in der der
ist ja schon gefährlicher sowie ein paar
wochen wird ein großes mitgliedsland der
europäischen union die eu verlassen
rexit das ist eigentlich eine
katastrophe
das ist in jeder hinsicht also für das
europäische projekt auch wenn wir uns
mittlerweile daran gewöhnt haben aber
wenn man sich nochmal die dimensionen
vorstellt an ein land auf das europa
angewiesen ist kehrt europa den rücken
und da geht es nicht nur darum die
briten zu beschuldigen sondern zu fangen
was ist da passiert was ist da falsch
gelaufen das heißt wir sind ja schon
mitten in der mitten im problemen oder
mitten in der katastrophe und das was
den polen passiert ist bei einer
unumkehrbar was in ungarn passiert das
unumkehrbar was in amerika unumkehrbar
also jedenfalls in ungarn wenn man sich
schauen wenn der verfassung
umgeschrieben werden wenn richter
wenn das die gewaltenteilung und
praktischen aufgehoben ist dann da ist
alles und er war jedenfalls aber für die
nächsten jahre muss man sich dran
gewöhnen und der trend geht ja auch
eindeutig in die richtung also warten
wir die nächsten italienischen wahlen ab
dann haben wir noch einen weiteren orban
und zwar im boot sitzen und dann geht es
so weiter und so weiter hat europa
insgesamt diese idee europa wir alle
einig und ländern mit individuellen
freiheiten mit gewaltenteilung mit
demokratie hat das den glanz verloren
ist das auf dem absteigenden ast
also jedenfalls ist die tendenz nicht
gut und die frage ist was kommt jetzt
also gibt es eine neue generation ich
glaube diejenigen die jetzt an der jetzt
das sagen haben auch in europa ich
glaube die haben immer noch nicht
begriffen welche stunde geschlagen hat
dass diese europäische projekt das wir
von unseren eltern und großeltern geerbt
haben dass das wunderbarste projekt und
das erstaunlichste projekt auf diesem
kontinent ist dass es innerhalb einer
generation eine eine ganze geschichte
von kriegen von völkermord von
nationalismus von hast also denken sie
nur daran wie noch in unserer kindheit
also ich weiß nicht wir sind ja die sind
ungefähr ungefähr so alt ich war ich
kann mich erinnern in meiner eigenen
schulzeit war es meine mitschüler
schwierig in frankreich eine gastfamilie
zu finden so groß war der hass noch in
den beginn der 80er jahre zwischen
deutschland und frankreich
das ist komplett verschwunden das ist
eigentlich unvorstellbar geworden und
ich hoffe dass eine eine generation
heranwächst das jedoch ein seine chance
hat das europäische projekt fortzuführen
dass wir es zu mindestens noch nicht
ganz zerstört haben wenn die das ruder
übernehmen
und dass das tolle an der geschichte ist
ja dass das so wie uns das sie
unvorhersehbar ist das dann wenn man
eigentlich glaubt alles läuft schief
immer wieder auch auch dinge passieren
die man nicht erwartet und das vor allem
auch geschichte nicht einfach passiert
sondern gemacht wird schauen sie wenn
sie ihr ziel wenn sich um wenden da ist
die sagen wir schauen nicht nur auf dem
bahnhofsvorplatz schauen zugleich oder
ich zumindest auf den dom
ich meine dass das 600 700 jahre hat es
gebraucht bis der gebaut worden
zwischendurch wurde gab's stillstand und
alle dachten das wird nie was und am
ende mit hilfe der preußen also der
fremden hat es dann doch geklappt und
dann gehen sie noch mal 75 jahre jetzt
75 jahre zurück wie es hier aussah als
ob es da hoffnung gegeben hätte in
deutschland das war ja alles zerstört
und schauen sie das ist dann das ist
gelungen und es war damals eine
europäische union einen frieden zwischen
nation europa war damals komplett
unvorstellbar und es ist gelungen
und warum sonst soll das
unwahrscheinliche was im augenblick eine
wo die bedingung und auch heute noch wie
viel besser sind um noch dinge zu
bewegen
warum sollte das nicht wieder gelingen
wir werden sehen
danke ein skeptischer optimist
nachrichten von gundula gause eine
messerattacke während des jüdischen
lichterfestes raluca im us bundesstaat
new york hat weltweit entsetzen
ausgelöst
der gouverneur des staates stufte den
anschlag auf das haus eines rabbiners
als terrorakt ein
in der nacht auf heute hatte ein mann
das privathaus gestürmt und wahllos auf
die gäste eingestochen
fünf menschen wurden verletzt die
polizei konnte die mutmaßlichen täter
festnehmen
in new york hat es allein in dieser
woche zehn antisemitische straftaten
gegeben
in australien sind die verheerenden
buschbrände weiterhin außer kontrolle
trotzdem hält sydney an dem traditionell
ersten großen feuerwerk der welt zu
neujahr fest 260.000 australier hatten
mit einer petition versucht das
spektakel zu verhindern
sie halten es für zynisch angesichts der
seit monaten andauernden
brandkatastrophe die bislang neun
menschen das leben kostete und eine
fläche von der größe belgiens vernichtet
hat in sydney wird morgen wieder mit
mehr als 40 grad hitze gerechnet bei
zwei lawinenabgängen in den alpen sind
an diesem wochenende vier deutsche ums
leben gekommen
ein 55 jähriger verunglückte im kanton
wallis nach einer station kurz danach
verschüttete eine lawine im südtiroler
schnalstal mehrere skifahrer
obwohl sie auf einer gesicherten piste
fugen eine frau aus thüringen ihre
tochter und ein weiteres mädchen starben
um mitternacht beginnt der flugbegleiter
streik der gewerkschaft ufo bis
einschließlich neujahr hat die
fluggesellschaft germanwings die flüge
auch für euro ins ausführt mehr als 170
starts abgesagt betroffen sind vor allem
innerdeutsche verbindungen waren im
tarifkonflikt mit der konzernmutter
lufthansa wieder verhandelt wird ist
noch unklar
so genannte stolpersteine erinnern in
ganz deutschland und europaweit an die
opfer der nazi diktatur eine idee des
künstlers gunter demnig der die aktion
mitte der 90er jahre ins leben gerufen
hat heute verlegte demnig in memmingen
den 75 tausendsten stolperstein in
erinnerung an die jüdische familie
rosenbaum die ihr zuhause verlassen
musste um vor den nazis zu fliehen
auch diese stolpersteine sind ein
weiteres zeichen gegen das vergessen wer
das wort chaos zum markenzeichen seiner
unternehmung macht will wahrscheinlich
keine anerkennung vom establishment das
wollten sie wohl nicht als vor fast 40
jahren in berlin der chaos computer club
gegründet wurde in den redaktionsräumen
der taz am tisch der alten kommune 1
inzwischen ist der sogenannte club eine
unverzichtbare organisation
bürgerschaftlichen engagement geworden
diese anerkennung müssen die aushalten
ohne ccc würden die regeln der digitalen
welt vollends hinter verschlossenen
türen zwischen industrie verbänden und
behörden ausgekungelt den sätzen die
hacker von ccc ihr können und ihren
aktivismus entgegen einmal im jahr steht
dieses kürzel hochseriös für chaos
kommunikation kongress zur zeit in lathi
ziemlich beste freunde waren die
sympathisanten des chaos computer clubs
und die institutionen des staates wohl
nie seit jeher haben die computer
aktivisten angst vor zu viel überwachung
und staatlicher kontrolle der staat als
datenkrake
das ist bei der verschärfung des
gesetzes gegen hass kriminalität im netz
nicht anders
dabei lehnt gerade dieser teil der
netzgemeinde rassistische drohungen mit
tod und gewalt scharf ab das trifft
natürlich meistens irgendwie ohnehin
schon diskriminierte gruppen und die
werden dann noch weiter an den rand
gedrängt und das darf nicht weiter so
gehen da muss auf jeden fall den leuten
geholfen werden dass der staat bei der
verfolgung der täter die betreiber
sozialer medien notfalls zur herausgabe
von passwörtern zwingen will geht der
szene aber zu weit
die herausgabe von daten ist einfach nur
ein vorwand die herausgabe von daten
einzuführen das hat mit der hate speech
gar nichts zu tun mit dem phänomen hass
und rassismus im netz beschäftigt sich
der fachjournalist michael krahl seit
langem drohungen die gegen die
politikerin sowie schibli sind für ihn
nur die spitze eines eisberges der sei
das eigentliche problem nicht die
radikalisierung der sprache also die
entgrenzung hat den letzten jahren
zugenommen und zwar hauptsächlich weil
tatsächlich die angst vor dem islam
zugenommen hat wir haben es mit mit dem
mit bei hate speech und mit
morddrohungen mit einem phänomen zu tun
dass insbesondere eine sehr kleine
gruppe betrifft zumindest das was wir
auf twitter beobachten können dass es
zahlenmäßig vielleicht nur ein prozent
aber von dem gesetz sind alle betroffen
eine verschärfung der staatlichen
kontrolle stehe in keinem verhältnis zum
ergebnis
naja also insbesondere wenn es um die
herausgabe von passwörtern geht ist das
völlig unverhältnismäßig
um gegen hate speech vorzugeben
passwörter sichern ja meine privatsphäre
und das komplett dem staat in die hände
zu geben auf grundformen von hate speech
dass es halt einfach unverhältnismäßig
die grundthese von kreisstadt passwörter
auszuforschen solle sich der staat
lieber um die prävention kümmern denn
rassismus als massenphänomen sei das
grundproblem
damit spricht er wohl den meisten hier
aus der seele
also das kernproblem an rassistischer
gewalt ist nicht nur die gewalt sondern
der rassismus dahinter und das ist ein
unglaublich komplexes und schwieriges
thema mit dem wir uns als gesellschaft
konfrontiert sehen dass wir uns mit dem
thema rassismus auseinandersetzen müssen
doch der widerspruch bleibt mehr
staatlich
die kontrolle um täter zu verfolgen
stehen gegen die freiheitsrechte des
einzelnen und umgekehrt
ein kompromiss ist dabei kaum möglich
wenden wir uns nach norden ganz nach
norden zum polarkreis der durchzieht
grönland kanada alaska russland finnland
schweden und norwegen jetzt in der
dunklen eisigen polarnacht wirkt das eis
dort oben dick und unangreifbar
satellitendaten aber zeigen seit winter
1979 deutlich die eisfläche geht in den
sommermonaten immer weiter zurück und
kann sich im winter nicht mehr genug
aufbauen
sie ist auf dem zweitniedrigsten stand
seit dass solche aufnahmen gibt russland
usa und kanada teilen sich den großteil
des polarkreises unsere korrespondenten
bei den arktischen mächten für legalen
russland und johannes hano für
nordamerika waren dort unterwegs und
zeigen was die veränderungen für
menschen und tiere bedeuten
es ist eine reise in eine raue
unwirkliche welt eine welt über die alle
sprechen und jedoch kaum jemand kennt
die arktis
viele tausend kilometer sind wir
unterwegs rund um den polarkreis in
regionen die einsamer kaum sein könnte
nun in denen sich doch die zukunft der
menschheit entscheiden wird es ist ein
großes abenteuer
allein der transport oft an den nerven
zehrt die ursprüngliche fast
märchenhafte schönheit an der
grönländischen ostküste macht uns klar
dass wir dabei sind zu verlieren die
gletscher schmelzen in den letzten
jahren immer stärker
vor zehn jahren waren viele bestimmt
noch einen kilometer länger in der
kanadischen nordwest passage erleben wir
was es heißt die kontrolle über ein
gebiet zu behalten das wegen seiner
rohstoffe immer mehr zum schauplatz der
konfrontation der großmächte wird mein
kommando bereich umfasst die drei
kanadischen territorium yukon nordwest
territorium und nun wird wenn du das
zusammen nimmst dann ist das gebiet etwa
so groß wie die usa in diesem gebiet
aber leben nur 115.000 menschen verteilt
auf 72 gemeinden die herausforderungen
sind kommunikation transport
infrastruktur alles ist eine
herausforderung im norden
und im norden alaskas erfahren wir dass
die energiesicherheit der welt auf dem
spiel steht wenn der permafrost taut auf
der reise von spitzbergen bis nach
ostsibirien treffen wir auch menschen
die der klimaerwärmung beherzt
entgegentreten
im arktischen sommer zeigt uns sergej
sie muss wie er den permafrost retten
will der wissenschaftler lässt in einem
teil jakutien die eiszeit wieder
aufleben
flora und fauna wie vor 12.000 jahren
seien resistenter gegen den klimawandel
als das heutige ökosystem meint er yaks
und wisente tun schon ihr bestes wenn es
nach dem russen ginge dürfte gerne auch
wieder ein mammut hier einziehen
ich will meinen enkeln und urenkeln
nicht diese armseligen örtliche
landschaft hinterlassen in der sich nur
mücken wohlfühlen sondern die richtige
artenreiche natur unsere vorfahren die
art natur die das klima stabilisiert und
millionen menschen ernähren
wohin wir auch kommen überall spüren wir
wie sich der alltag der menschen in der
arktis verändert völker wie die nenzen
oder tschuktschen sind seit jeher
perfekt an die harschen bedingungen
jenseits des polarkreises angepasst
eisbären und walrosse gehören zu ihrem
leben sterben die tiere ausgehen auch
kultur und tradition der menschen
verloren
die wenigen ureinwohner auf dieser erde
egal ob in dieser oder in einer anderen
region haben der natur noch nie großes
leid zugefügt
und das ist etwas was man vom weißen man
nicht behaupten kann
es ist eine reise in eine fremde welt in
der man uns zeigt wie man als joker für
den winter vorsorgt eine reise in eine
welt die uns bei allen schwierigkeiten
immer wieder aufs neue fasziniert
nordlichter leben am polarkreis teil 1
läuft am neujahrstag abends 23 20 im zdf
das ist ziemlich spät aber ab morgen
stehen die beiden teile in der mediathek
und warten 24 stunden jeden tag auf ihr
klick auf den stadtteil tun sich
eingefallen und schauen sie zu dass sie
diese bilder auf den tollsten schirm
ziehen denen sie anspielen können und
auch der letzte sonntag in diesem jahr
hat sport und erfolge beim
auftaktspringen der vierschanzentournee
in oberstdorf ist lokalmatador karl
geiger zweiter geworden
umjubelt von mehr als 25.000 zuschauern
in der arena im allgäu gewonnen hat das
erste springen der prestigeträchtigsten
skisprung serie titelverteidiger
probieren
der japaner siegte mit sprüngen auf 138
und 134 meter und stellte einen neuen
rekord auf der fünfte tagessieg am stück
das nächste springen am mittwoch in
garmisch überträgt das zdf ab 14 uhr das
letzte slalom weltcup rennen des jahres
im österreichischen lienz hat michaela
chiffren aus den usa gewonnen vor petra
fleischer aus der slowakei und der
schweizerin michelle gisin mit platz
fünf und sechs verpassten christina
ackermann aus oberstdorf und lena dürr
aus germering das podest nur knapp
einen interessanten neuzugang gibt es
aus der fußball-bundesliga zu melden der
norweger erling holland geht zu borussia
dortmund der jungstar von rb salzburg
war von einigen europäischen top klubs
top clubs umworben und hat nun beim bvb
einen vertrag bis sommer 2004 und 20
unterschrieben
schon am freitag soll der 19-jährige mit
den dortmundern ins trainingslager ein
meter 94 groß ist der stürmer der
champions league in diesem jahr in sechs
spielen acht tore erzielt das nächste
woche ein jahres und jahrzehnt wechsel
bevor steht das braucht ihn keiner mehr
zu erzählen
christian von rechenberg blickt auf drei
andere termine einer woche die dekaden
überspannt
[Musik]
am montag blickt der deutsche
wetterdienst auf das jahr zurück so viel
verraten die experten vorab
es war sehr heiß seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen 1881 war dieses jahr das
drittwärmste und es hat einen platz im
geschichtsbuch
noch nie hat man bei uns drei tage
hintereinander mehr als 40 grad gemessen
das war im juli fracht und kreuzfahrer
werden auf hoher see ab dem neujahrstag
sauberer neues gesetz im treibstoff der
schiffe darf nur noch 0,5 prozent
schwefel drin sein
85 prozent weniger als vorher heißt die
reedereien müssen neuen sauberen
treibstoff kaufen kostet mehr macht die
kreuzfahrt oder die waren aber nicht
wesentlich teurer
umweltschützer finden es einen
riesenschritt
und gleich am nächsten tag können wir
die sondermarke beethoven kaufen 626
millionen stück hat die post produziert
rekord und damit rein ins beethoven ja
aktionen aufführungen ausstellungen und
natürlich seine musik deutschland und
die welt zelebriert einen giganten und
das wetter bleibt über neuer hinweg
ruhig wenig winterlich und erstaunlich
sonnig morgen gibt es nur im osten und
nordosten zeitweise wolken sonst nach
nebelauflösung recht viel sonne bei
minus zwei grad im dauernebel bis plus
zehn grad im westen und über den
jahreswechsel wird es teils freundlich
teils stark bewölkt oder neblig trüb
dort ist es meist frostig sonst werden
bis zu neun grad erreicht morgen
erwarten wir sie zum letzten
heute-journal dieses jahrzehnts klingt
bombastisch mit den nachrichten des
tages und unserem jahresrückblick später
kürzer kompakter als andere und wir
hoffen mindestens so berühmt bist dann
stehen abend
[Musik]